welcome to the second panel of this
morning the ethics and Paula
version 2.0 my name is Ted by field and
it's my tremendous honor to be the
moderator of this panel it's especially
in honor because my role here will be
largely functor II we initially had plan
to have a format similar to the first
where we would have two speakers a Q&A
two speakers and then a QA Jonathan
Zittrain who needs no introduction but
I'll introduce emulator anyway agreed to
join us and so he's going to wrap up the
discussion and I think probably in the
best way as many of the people in this
room know you cannot really wrap up
these conversations because they tend to
be very open-ended so we will have for
sneakers and then Jonathan will sort of
take over the sort of substantive role I
need to stress again what lured an
artist said earlier and that is that
there is in fact a solemn occasion
starting a few minutes after one and
that we need to really clear out of here
with what they used to call military
precision I'm not sure if they still do
anymore so without further ado a couple
of very brief remarks about this idea of
the ethics and politics of library
version 2 point 0 as if it weren't
enough to be tasked with the stewardship
of one of the most rarified forms of
material culture the book and things
like this the idea that librarians have
additionally been sort of saddled with
the task of dealing with these issues in
other refractory forms under this word
digital makes things especially
problematic I think in large part
because we're only beginning to really
understand what digital means we've seen
some of the sort of first signs and sort
of tremors of it but really what it
means and where it's going and indeed
how it works is not so clear so then the
idea that four or five people would be
able to talk about the ethics and
politics of something that's so
complicated which in turn was already
complicated to begin with is very
problematic but we have some fantastic
speakers today the first of which is
going to be Mary Alice beige who has
spends her days and probably nights as
well serving I think is a very sort of
serious advocate for public library are
I'm sorry legal libraries their users
and both directly and indirectly because
of that
the public at large so I'm going to try
to keep my intros to each person as
brief as possible so they can establish
their own context here is Mary Alice
thanks very much
thank you very much and thanks for the
planners of this wonderful symposium
today I hope you can see the slides okay
they'll be posted on the website along
with a resource list of a number of
items that some of you might want to
follow up on when President Clinton
pushed the federal government into web
1.0 resulting in the creation of
thousands of agency websites seemingly
overnight this new level of openness and
transparency really transformed the way
that the government works and vastly
improved the public's access
unfortunately as we soon discovered not
enough attention was paid at that time
to managing the lifecycle of electronic
government information including online
and this is especially true from the
point of its creation through its
preservation I'm going to just give a
quick view of why today I'm not as
cynical as I was say three four or five
years ago about everything and it starts
with Obama and change gov candidate
Obama made the most effective use of the
internet and web 20 during his
presidential campaign bringing millions
of supporters together and getting daily
updates which some people such as myself
still receive these people met online at
the local level they held neighborhood
meetings in their own homes and they had
an easy way to collaborate with the
Obama campaign also during the campaign
Obama was the only presidential
candidate to actually have a
transparency pledge on his website he
spoke repeatedly and effectively about
the need to change the Bush era of
secrecy in Washington towards one of
openness and innovation true to his word
the president's set a transition team
that included members on technology
groups and also on transparency groups
the transition team sent out invitations
to your seat at the table and they
actually received more than 18,000
posted sets of comments from individuals
as well as organizations double a double
submitted comments to the transition
team and included among them or two that
I think are very important especially to
this audience one is no fee public
access to the pacer system for the
electronic court information and the
second one is a public domain citation
system for all federal legal information
in addition I'd like to just mention
briefly a report that I was involved
with as a member the steering committee
of open the government org which was
created in 2003 to sort of be able to
track and speak out against the secrecy
of the Bush administration and the
process of getting these reports and
recommendations which do include web 20
technologies was about a year and a half
long process in addition as part of his
one of his first memorandums on his very
first day in office it was on open
government and transparency President
Obama has requested that there be an
openness government directive that is
due to him on May 21st and with that
announcement he has embraced the core
principles of a democracy which are that
government should be transparent that it
should be participatory and that it also
should be collaborative in other good
news members of the White House Office
of Science and Technology Policy have
been meeting with open government groups
and individuals and all stakeholders
actually immediately after the
inauguration day to find out what we as
open government advocates need from the
federal government and even better news
that in meetings that we've had with
these white house officials they are
asking all the right questions and they
are listening attentively to our answers
the White House embraces web 20 and I
think the president finally got
permission to use his blackberry which
was the issues there have to do with the
fact that his communications are
presidential records in our view the Sun
shines now on his white house website in
fact i went online on at 12 02 as he was
moving to the podium for his inaugural
speech and swearing in and was delighted
to see that among the early presidential
pledges he made on the website was that
all non-emergency bills sent to him by
congress will be made available on the
site for five days and there would be an
opportunity for public comment on them
the website also includes a blog which
is very informative but it's only a
one-way communication tool at this point
president obama also held a very
successful online town meeting on march
19th in which he took questions
electronically from participants the
White House is also exploring new
functionalities and I think this is very
important because in the tone of
collaboration the president's wants
two-way communications and so they don't
yet have the full functionality of
allowing public comments and an exchange
with staff but they are working towards
it and they recognize that that is an
important need for their site I've also
been pleased to find at the White House
website announcements about some new
databases that have been created such as
recovery.gov and most recently financial
stability gov and just want to these are
databases to help the public and all
stakeholders track the bailout money and
how it is being used these are new
databases that some might say were
launched before they were ready in terms
of their lack of completeness and many
in many areas they're not at all robust
but in my opinion they're a step in the
right direction and I'm sure we'll see
vast improvements to them these
databases really bring greater
transparency and clarity to the
immensely complex problems in the
financial system and the president
plans to address them also changes for
the White House these are some
challenges these are things that were
part of recommendations many of us made
and that was for President Obama to name
the first White House chief technology
officer this position has yet to be
filled but I know they're working on
qualifications and as much as I
understand of it the main
responsibilities will be to be in charge
of access and also protect privacy how
many of you have used the White House
website I mean it you may be as
frustrated as I that information is very
hard to find part of the problem is that
most documents are not in searchable
PDFs and if you try to print something
off it's kind of messy a colleague of
mine Steven Aftergood of secrets out the
secrecy newsletter noted and one of his
recently recent postings that three very
important national security documents
were not available on the White House
website the ofr and the White House
announced on january 21st that they were
discontinuing the weekly compilation of
presidential documents and replacing it
with a daily compilation that's been a
problem some of my very astute while
library colleagues have noticed that the
information on the daily compilation is
days sometimes even as long as a week
after the information has been posted to
the White House website one of the
challenging and new innovative databases
that they are working on is something
called data gov some you it is sort of a
data dump but it raises a number of
important issues as agencies are asked
to put their raw data into this new
broad database there are concerns about
the ownership of the information there
are concerns about the preservation of
the information how the information is
reliable and authoritative as others
choose to take it and do their own
mashups briefly the challenges of
e-government lifecycle management
ones that I've been preaching somewhat
unsuccessfully in Washington for the
last 15 years and that's at the point of
creation of information the government
has to begin to think about every other
part of the life cycle including down to
the preservation area government's need
to provide robust finding tools
including the use of metadata
governments have to be very careful
about version control and as a post new
documents to the website must be very
careful that they do not take down
earlier versions of an important
document for the legal community we want
to see the government's legal
information at all levels of government
we want to know whether that online
version is or is not official for this
community I'm now putting citation as I
mentioned one of our goals is to have
the federal government adopt a public
domain citation system this really
should be part of a lifecycle management
it's very important to the legal
community and I think to any user of
information from the government or its
data that we know that it is capable of
authentication that it is its integrity
has been assured permanent accessibility
and that was a problem with the early
early Clinton year websites where they
might put a annual report up and when
the next year came around they'd put the
new one and take down the old one we
need permanent accessibility to these
materials and also the enormous
challenges of preservation of online and
other electronic information so in the
web 20 environment as the White House
has already indicated its intention to
use YouTube and Facebook and Flickr and
myspace the enormity of the challenges
of including that in the e lifecycle
especially as preservation are extremely
important as I mentioned with data gov
I'm concerned about third-party bulk
downloads and mashups how do we ensure
the ownership the integrity and the
authentication of that government
information in addition agencies must
comply with certain laws and regulations
privacy
security FOIA and section 508 of the
Americans with Disabilities Act and what
about the digital divide and I'm glad
John mention it we must keep in mind
that there are many parts of our country
that are not yet accessible by a quick
internet access and there are so many
Americans who cannot afford computers
I'd like to briefly end on an agency
case study and how we change the culture
of an agency and it's regarding the
Environmental Protection Agency EPA
announced plans to close five of their
libraries in spring 2006 without having
much plans other than to dismantle the
entire collection what would happen to
it they really told us that they wanted
to go all electronic and digitize all
the materials in the clothes libraries
which included three regional libraries
as well as the DC headquarters and
chemical library it was all going to be
digital available to everybody on their
website stakeholders including
librarians law professors spoke out
loudly and effectively and we were very
pleased at the beginning of 110 Congress
when oversight hearings were held on the
EPA that included a discussion of the
closure of the library and the results
is that EPA was ordered by Congress to
reopen the libraries by September of
last year which they did unfortunately
they only got a million dollars to do so
but they have also promised to hire
professional librarians which is good
news so in fact that sort of story about
how an agency totally failed to
understand how its information is used
by the public by stakeholders by
libraries it taught a lesson to them
they have changed their culture they now
use web 20 blogs and online chat rooms
and stakeholder comment opportunities
even at the local level and they have
learned that this input from the
community has really helped them better
achieve the mission of the agency so in
closing I just want to reiterate that
we've talked and heard a lot about the
issues of preservation at libraries and
digitization and libraries and web 20
the federal government is in the middle
of it I don't give them an a by any ways
or means and I think there is a role for
libraries as well to participate either
in becoming digital repositories for
some of the government information and
making sure that it is preserved and
available perhaps even outside of the
federal government thank you very much
and thank you very much our second
speaker is Michael Zimmer and I'm sorry
I'm good to review my notes for a second
because I'm actually a little bit
nervous he's an assistant professor at
the School of Information studies at the
University of Wisconsin in Milwaukee and
he is also a former fellow of the
information society project so it's
fantastic to have him back his work in
the realm of sort of privacy ethics
access to knowledge and so on is very
much I think at the heart of the kind of
the the kinds of questions that are
coming up in this conference and she is
sort of i think optimism but also
pessimism is also very much of the
essence as well so without further ado
here is
great Thank You Todd and thank you to
Jack Laura Leah and everyone else at the
ISP for putting on this event I remember
it's about a year ago that we sat down
at lunch at cosi and started talking
about this and I'm really excited to see
what what we've been able to pull
together today hopefully you'll be able
to see my slides I don't know if the
lights can be dimmed from up here from
the back what I want to talk about like
Ted was mentioning was sort of this
intersection between library to point o
the drive for getting better access to
knowledge and concerns we have over
privacy especially patron that a patient
confidentiality intellectual freedom and
the type of values that librarians
traditionally hold very dear to
themselves and I like to view this
through the frame of a Faustian bargain
this is a quote from neil postman who
has lucky to study with before his death
and he pointed out that technology
technical change is always a Faustian
bargain that both giveth and taketh away
not always an equal measure but we need
to understand that there's two sides of
any technology that enters any
information ecosystem and that's what I
want to use sort of as the framework for
us to think about library 2.0 from a
political ethical perspective over the
course of the day today of course we
can't you know be hosted by the ISP
without talking about access to
knowledge a core principle and then a
drive for human values and human
development idea and the group at Yale
has been at the forefront of this of
this movement and access to knowledge
and libraries share many of the same
core principles and I'm going to not go
over each of these just for the note but
perton concern over time my slides are
online but ensuring freedom of inquiry
free and open access to information so I
access the knowledge and those of you in
the room who come from the librarian
perspective you know you share a lot of
the same key issues and key principles
driving your work and driving your
day-to-day activities but as we know
libraries of course are at sort of a
cross roads are increasingly being
confronted by new technologies web
driven technologies social media user
driven technologies were confronted with
challenges to the historical profession
the
the the professionalisation the
expertise that a librarian brings to our
information ecosystem is decreasing Lee
being challenged and of course budgetary
issues that we're dealing with right now
I know everyone is in this room he
understands all these threats all these
concerns and libraries are facing today
and library two point oh of course is
why we're here it's what perhaps it's
one of these solutions it's one of the
ways that we might be able to confront
some of these challenges and help sort
of reaffirm the role of the library in
providing access to knowledge but this
is where Faust comes in you need to
remember Faustus trying to achieve
universal knowledge and the way for him
to do that was to make a deal with the
devil I don't think our moral dilemma as
quite as apocalyptic as that but we need
to be concerned we need to ensure that
we're not making a similar bargain as we
march down the path towards using these
great technologies within our library
systems that we just at least take
somewhat of a cautionary principle and
try to acknowledge that there could be
something that it's both being given and
taken away when we embrace library two
point oh so where did some of the ways
that we might be engaging in this kind
of Faustian bargain generally the
challenges of user-generated content
Josh greenberg talked about this already
this morning we'll talk more about it
this afternoon what happens when
libraries start hosting user-generated
content you start letting you know
library patrons post reviews of books
make comments about books who owns that
content we need to be worried about the
intellectual property would if I cut and
paste a review from amazon or from
Publishers Weekly and post it on to the
library website as a review of that book
whatever concerns there it's also great
concerned about noise one of my
colleagues refers to user generated
content as loser generated content which
we've all seen that too right so there's
a concern within the profession of
course about okay so what happens when
we start opening up categorization
reviewing recommendation comments our
blogs or wiki's to every patron that we
serve and is there going to be some
noise
in this information that's coming from
our users and how do we sort through
that how do we do with that so there's a
given a take here of course doing with
user-generated content and because of a
lot of these kind of concerns many
librarians are recognizing they need to
start monitoring these patron activities
need to monitor the comments that
patrons leave on their library hosted
blogs or monitor the reviews that are
left for copyright issues for profanity
for obscenities first land or for libel
this of course makes many librarians are
comfortable you know freedom of
expression is a core principle and all
of a sudden we need to start you know
paying a little bit more attention about
what's happening on library systems and
there's a challenge there so I both give
the thin it and it taketh away and third
that I'll highlight is this issue of
tracking a patriot activity a variety of
library to point out features and
functions and I'll walk through a couple
of examples really require the capture
of patron activity in ways that
librarians have traditionally stood up
against so this is going to be one of
the key issues that I want to sort of
focus on for the next few minutes of
this talk what are the ways that that
patron data might be captured and what
can we do about this so we think about
personalization of course there's a huge
you know push to make library websites
portals and services more personalized
you make a better connection with your
patrons you make the information more
relevant to them many great reasons for
this but by its very nature that means
you're going to start creating user
accounts you start asking patrons what
are your interests either research
interests or personal interests you
might even personalize based on their
neighborhood or other other types of
hobbies other things you know you can
just think about creating you know a
version of my yahoo for your library
this is an early version of cornell's my
library there's a lot of platforms out
there to do this but in Herring with
this you're going to start creating a
larger data set of what I am as a
library patron and what my interests are
and you're going to have that data
housed within within your systems
so is going to be concerned there about
capturing some of my personal interests
that otherwise may not be as freely
shared of them within the library system
recommendation systems a growing
movement is basically create you know an
Amazon type algorithm for library
services and this would be great you
imagine other patrons that checked out
this book also checked out these three
books maybe you'd be interested in that
I would love to see that when I'm
searching through you know my academic
library but in order to make these
algorithms work in order to just sort of
serve that long tail it requires an
incredible amount of information and
data and this is what you know amazon
netflix and even google from their
perspective that's is what they're good
at collecting that data and crunching
those numbers so if we're going to go
down that path we need to be recognized
that we're going to have large data sets
of patron activity both are borrowing
activity and even what they do on OPEC
where they took clickstream data all
this kind of information that you hear
people like me complain about Google
having now I need to be thinking about
whether or not you know my local library
also has this kind of information
participating in social networking this
is probably the easiest way for
libraries to enter the 2 point 0 world
create a facebook page create a myspace
page now start finding patrons start
pushing that it that way but inherent
with any participation in these networks
all of a sudden you're taking you not
only taking this sort of library patron
interface outside of the library into a
different context you inevitably get
access to patron information you know
the Friends of my facebook feed can see
what I'm doing and depending on how I
control my flow of information you as a
librarian there is an institution might
suddenly have access to information that
you didn't want to know you didn't
didn't want to know what that patron was
doing last night and they just posted
some pictures and beating the way that
some of these platforms are built some
of that data is just pushed
automatically to you so you need to be
concerned about what we do with that
data how we interface with these kind of
these kind of platforms and finally I'll
talk a little bit about creating
third-party applications or widgets this
is a great opportunity for libraries to
start providing their services
pushing them out to patrons so instead
of building a very robust website for
yourself create a small little widget
for interacting with the reference desk
or for accessing the catalog or for
helping students with their homework
they post that widget on their mutton on
their facebook page or under iGoogle
homepage or on the dashboard of their
mac or on their iphone and they can they
can access your services that way on
their own terms and it's a great
opportunity but the concern here most of
these platforms for this kind of
information exchange are built on an
advertising model they're built with the
intention that you're going to want to
collect information about what patron
but what your customers are doing with
these widgets you're going to get all
kinds of flows of information coming
back to you because that's how these
platforms are built this is just an
example of a facebook app where the
whole purpose of that app is to show
people how much information you're
sharing just by installing a facebook
application so you can install the
vampire bite application or some of
these silly things that we have on
Facebook but you're actually sharing
with those developers pretty much
everything in your profile and a lot of
things in your friends profiles so
that's something we need to be concerned
with whom we start thinking about these
kind of these kind of concerns so from
you know contextually everyone in the
room understands what's on this slide
librarians have had a strong historical
resistance to having patron that the
original libraries Bill of Rights
various things various instances in the
history of libraries USA PATRIOT Act and
the concerns with whether or not the
government could access Patriot
information libraries perhaps even
people in this room just started
deleting databases they just didn't want
to be in that kind of position so of
course we're starting to face this now
this is our Faustian bargain if we have
this history we have this ethics as
librarians and information professionals
but as we enter into this library two
point O realm we need to understand how
does it give it has it taketh away how
do we approach how do we deal with this
I'm running out of time so I just want
to quickly talk about you know libraries
could resist to point o we could say
we're going to stand back we're going to
be the last say
harbor for completely anonymous and
confidential information seeking
activities and just let everything else
happen on its own and we'll stay in this
sort of you know final bastion or we
could embrace library to point o pursue
it will collect some data and we might
retreat a little bit from our sort of
historical and traditional reluctant
towards having this kind of information
so if we take that as our position one
of the things that I think we need to be
concerned with an approach are
developing some best practices and this
is something that's a work in progress
for me and look forward to talking and
working with you know all of you in this
room in terms of how to develop these
kind of best practices for libraries
following the code of Fair Information
practices making sure that patrons are
don't have proper notice and consent and
in fact reminding them of what's being
collected you know Facebook you click
off the Terms of Service and you forget
about it two years later you're sharing
all kinds of stuff that you didn't think
about when you first clicked ok on that
so let's remind our patrons you know by
the way you're sharing this information
create separate accounts when we can if
we're going to do the slick to point o
stuff keep it separate from their actual
borrowing account unless they agree to
put them together you know and we build
that kind of infrastructure avoid
external data collection when we're
doing social media avoid using tracking
cookies it's great that the White House
does everything they do but when they
throw on YouTube videos and get a google
cookie and you go to the page you know
there's a problem there but we need to
be aware of those kind of those kind of
concerns and those kind of issues
anonymizer activity logs to the best we
can and we can talk more about this
because this is not a perfect solution
and there's been a lot of examples about
how anonymous quote unquote blogs can be
relied with relative ease but it's an
important step for us to take and of
course you know don't give the data to
anybody not to the government not to
advertisers not your development team
not to your fundraisers you know keep
this kind of you know borrowing
collection activities tier cells for
your own internal processing well close
with that another quote from Neil what
I'm trying to do is just make sure that
we're not
putting on blinders so we understand the
ideological meanings behind our
technologies and so when we approached a
library two point O which I think we
should that we understand as bargain and
we're making we made the right kind of
decisions in order to make it helpful
and useful for our patrons in ourselves
so thank you very much